hello everyone this game was played in
2015 it was the millionaire chess
tournament and Hikaru Nakamura won this
tournament and by winning this
tournament he also won a prize of
$100,000 that's not a bad price but
aside from winning this beautiful prize
he also played this beautiful game put
the black pieces against the Russian
Grand Master Afghani brave and well okay
he was a Russian Grand Master till 2015
in 2015 he was transferred to the
Canadian Chess Federation so I believe
he's now a Canadian chess grandmaster
but nevertheless in 2003 mr. Burrell was
ranked number four in the world with a
rating of twenty seven hundred and
thirty nine so losing a game in 11 moves
with the white pieces is is definitely
something to see so brave is white and
Nakamura's black here Knight to f3 is
played so the ready opening we have D 5
D for now c6 Bishop to f4 Queen to b6 by
Nakamura not b3 protecting that b2 pawn
Knight to f6
we have III now Knight to h5 going for
that for Bishop now Bishop to g5 h6
Bishop to h4 and Knight to d7 and here
we have a well a blunder by mr. Barea he
plays Knight to e5 and Hiro Nakamura
immediately plays Knight captures an e5
and well Burrell has a problem here
if you capture tonight with D captures
on e5 you get Queen to b4 check and if
you after you cover up it over with the
Queen or with the night well simply
night to d2 you'll lose the bishop on h4
Queen captures on h4 so after this
Knight to e5 move beriev doesn't really
have a lot of options here he has to
play Queen captures on h5 grabbing the
night so we have Queen captures on h5
but now like a more place Knight to g4
and already you can see that this Queen
doesn't doesn't really have a lot of
squares to go to so Bishop to g3 was
played making room for the Queen
nakamura goes g6 attacking the queen
once again
the Queen doesn't really have anywhere
to go but h4 you don't really want to go
to h3 you get a discovery from this
Bishop on g4 sorry on c8 so twin th
forest played and the Hiro Nakamura
played Bishop to g7 and well this is
movie 11 and in this position
Grandmaster Evgeny Barea resigned the
game what's the idea well Nakamura is
threatening Queen to f6 and how do you
save the queen
you can play something like h3 because
well again simply Bishop to f6 captures
the Queen and well one move you can play
for example Bishop to e5 but if you play
Bishop d5 you get Knight captures on e5
d captures any five and now Bishop
captures on e5 with an attack on this
rook on a1 and after for example I'll
move like c3 Queen to c5 is played now
again attacking the c3 pawn with threats
of grabbing the rook I only move for
white here would be King to d2 and well
it would seem that Afghani barea is too
strong of a grandmaster to play a
position like this against Hikaru
Nakamura so yeah after this nice -
Bishop to g6 move burry resigned and the
world Nakamura won the $100,000
eventually so what do you think would
you I'm interested I don't know of
course this is far beyond my level but I
would play this position with white
against anyone you know I won't resign
him in this position I'm interested what
would you do here so yeah that's the
game I do hope you enjoyed this
miniature I don't think any channel
covered this game so far it's the first
time I saw it actually and yeah as
usually you can check two of my previous
videos here I think y'all for watching
and I will see you soon